get down the basic details of this
question with me you've got the word
decisions um it has calcium one two
three four plus two donate
nine characters
good morning grab a sheet
there are nine characters how many are
duplicates
you've got two pairs right two
pairs of duplicates
so the the eyes are duplicates and the
s's
are duplicates and one other piece of
impression which you don't know
immediately is useful but when you have
a look at b and c you realize you need
to know
is that i believe there are four vowels
and five consonants okay so let's just
drop that down
that's not always important but in this
question it is
and thankfully no matter why even anyway
okay now let's just have a look at this
really um
gently at the beginning i firstly
how many ways can we arrange this word
and there are no
conditions no restrictions associated
with them okay
so all of the information that we need
is up here it's only in the first two
lines
in fact okay um for part a and by the
way
as we break this down um i like to
sometimes
you know have a look at parts of the
question first ways to do this ways to
do that and then i summarize that by
saying
okay total ways okay in this case for
this first one
actually for the next couple um yeah
just for the first one
you can go straight to the total ways
like there's not that much sort of
extra subsidiary thinking required so
i'm going to write down total ways
no restriction how am i going to do this
can you talk me through what kind of
numbers i'm going to need
okay so the start is nine factorial now
you could alternatively have said 9p9
okay i know i'm using p not c because
because auto matters but how do i how do
i know the auto matter
can be arranged look for that key word
okay
so very good so i could have used 9p9
but 9.9 is nine factorial on
uh nine take away nine factorial that
denominator becomes one we
saw that yesterday so i can just write
it as nine factorial that's fine
but i've over counted haven't i because
of the duplicate letters right so i've
over counted for
um the eyes isn't that nice and i've
overcounted for the s's because i can
swap both of them and it looks exactly
the same
so what am i going to have in my
denominator here
and i'm done okay now i believe this
number comes out to
90 720.
we'll point out that number it doesn't
really matter it's
this this is what we look at okay so far
so good
all right now part b it says find out
how many ways the letters of the word
decisions can be arranged
so that the vowels and consonants
alternate
okay now have a look you've got four
vowels
and five consonants okay so what this
means and maybe you want to draw this
for yourself
is that if you think about your nine
letters in sequence
right
oh i got enough two four six yeah last
one
okay if i want them to alternate right
do i get a choice as to whether i start
with a vowel or a consonant
no i'm not yes i don't i don't really
get to choose i mean i can choose which
one
but i actually must start with a
consonant because of course if i start
with a vowel
i will run out of vowels and there will
be two consonants stuck together at the
end does that make sense
so therefore when i look at this the
first thing i'm going to drop down is
this
um this must start with a consonant then
a vowel then a consonant then a vowel
and so on okay does that make sense
now in a similar way to how i showed you
with the blocks
right i'm now going to consider this
as actually not one sequence of layers
but
two sequences of that letters that are
kind of doing their own thing right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take out all of the consonants first you
see they must occupy those spots
but they have to be there so i'm now
going to say all right pull them off to
the side
one two there are one two three four
five five consonants and they'll be in
some order right
how many ways are there to arrange these
guys okay good
so um ways for
um so all of this stuff on the in
on your piece of paper that'll all be
about question d okay so we're just sort
of setting up the beginning
so the ways for the consonants here it's
five things into five spots so it's five
factorial
okay and in the same way i have to
arrange the
vowels right there are four of them
good morning obviously take a piece of
paper so the ways for the vowels
is four factorial okay
okay now this doesn't take into account
the fact that i've got some repeats
so when you think about the consonants
one of the duplicates is a consonant but
the s's right so in fact it should
really be that
and then for the vowels you've got the
same deal right so there's the eyes and
that's
that's kind of duplicated okay now just
pause for a moment
because i just i did something which i
don't know if you noticed like oh i can
just do that
i pulled out each of these and i said
okay that's its own
sequence and i don't have to worry about
where they are that's a turn sequence i
don't have to worry about where they are
now here's my question why can i do that
why can't i just consider this one thing
as two separate things yeah because
there's only a fix
okay very good in case you didn't catch
it let me repeat it and then i'll unpack
it a little more
rash there which is exactly right
there's only a fixed pattern
for how these guys can actually slot
into these spots right the consonants
have to be in exactly those spots
mark this there are no choices i can't
choose where the consonants
which spots they're going to occupy good
morning i
they have to occupy spots one three five
seven
and nine right there's no other spots
they can occupy there are no more
choices
and this is why i asked at the beginning
before we i drew this box right
before i drew this box i asked could i
can i start with a vowel
or can i start with a consonant and you
all replied to me no
you must start with with this guy right
so there are no more choices right
so once i've locked that into place then
i just have to work out the order within
the slots
okay and that's where this comes up with
and so now i can say the total weights
how am i going to combine this pair of
numbers i'm going to multiply right
because i need the consonants
and the and and the vowels together
simultaneously
so the total ways is
five factorial four factorial on two
factorial two factorial
okay now what's lovely about having set
it up like this
is now look at part c
part c says arrange the same letters
so that the vowels come first followed
by
the consonants now think about what's
similar about this and think about
what's different
okay um obviously i can't use this
diagram can i
right so i'm going to draw a new one
this is part c
i'm going to draw a new one still have
nine slots
okay there you go there are my nine
slots i think i get that yeah i think so
having a look at this it's not cbc
the vowels come first right so thou
thou vowel vowel all four of them and
then the consonants one two three
four five okay now let me ask this again
are there any other arrangements for the
vowels and consonants
answer no because that's all they've
said right none of these vowels can
sneak over here now the consonants can
sneak over there
so i have no more choices
and then i say well think about these
guys as one
arrange them and then think about these
guys as one and arrange them
which we've already done do you see that
so even though this looks different to
this if you can see through they're the
same
question you still have to arrange
consonants you still have to arrange
vowels
but you don't have to arrange them with
each other there's only one way you can
do them so there are no more choices so
i don't have to multiply any of these
numbers by anything
um part c same answer does that make
sense
and there's the same number if i one of
the consonants first
and then the vowels or you get the idea
okay
all right so that was a b and c now we
need to have a look at d
can you have a look at it for a second
how many of you have attempted this
question
already okay not too many right thank
you hands down
before i spoil it for you how would you
think about answering this question
you're gonna arrange all these letters
but this is the condition you have to
meet okay i want to give you at least a
minute just to think about it on your
own
you don't have to get to an answer but
how would you start like see how this is
the way i approached it this is why
a way i've broken down i'm going to show
you a few ways that's what these
multiple pages are about
try not to look at them because they
they might give you a clue maybe they
weren't you're looking in the
i don't know okay how would you on your
own steam
come up with a way to start this
question i'll give you
one minute